well are there different tips for new
york actors versus la actors
uh i i think it's the
the same my experience from being here a
little bit is
there's a lot more i don't want to
say this the wrong way in new york
there's no real fake you can't fake it
in new york
because if you fake it in new york
you're going to have to leave new york
because the rent's higher
you know you just you can't afford to to
fake it in new york
you ha my experience from being in la
for the small
amount of time is that there's a lot of
ellie actors who call themselves actors
who are not
really actors they're not even trying
they just call themselves actors
in new york there's a lot of actors who
are are actors who are
really in classes every single day
hustling and hustling and hustling
and really trying to be creative where
here it's a lot of people are
trying to be famous rather than trying
to
work because the opportunities here
there's a lot more opportunities here
there really are there's a lot more work
here
it's one of the reasons why i moved here
a lot of theater here people
say that theater here in la's is
terrible
how who are you to judge that work is
work
make the most of it you know what i mean
if you're not working
go join a theater company there's a
bunch of them in north hollywood
i just art is art to me you know
and uh it's not all about film and
television theater is great
new york theater is some of the best art
in the world
um la theater is is fine
you know it's work what are some of the
things you've done to find
different la theater companies oh i
researched
as soon as i got here i was like well
don't have a manager don't need have an
agent don't really want to pay for an
acting class right now because i didn't
have much money
uh go join a theater company and from
that theater company
i was cast in a play that um had a great
run and got me
some reviews in la weekly so that was
that was great it was uh
trust by theater unleashed my theater
company
it was a great cast great production and
it was awesome it was like a i treat it
like a
fantastic acting class and an
opportunity to meet other great actors
and
perform in front of people like that's
what real actors do right
you